[Musique]
alors bonjour comment tu t'appelles
tchétchène de blagues sur youtube je
demande aux gens s'ils connaissent les
blagues un peu et stigmatisantes un peu
inavouables est ce que tu en connais way
sur ty brut à regarder derrière tes
peurs ou quoi alors vas-y c'est
lamentable à qui on a rappelé sans bras
c'est quoi vas-y tu vois je sais pas à
nantes 8 vols ont fait peu
[Applaudissements]
black pas méchamment en arabe
s'embrasser des clichés non les arras et
des voleurs
aujourd'hui sur 20 sur les gros durs
alors si tu écoutes moi c'est un mec qui
demande à son pote du coup sont pas de
groupe des partis cet été un lieu répond
bas en grèce c'est une blague entre les
gros dans vos jeux désolé va passer une
bonne journée se faisait doubler sur un
mois encore une fois c'est fait
[Musique]
aujourd'hui j'ai un petit concept je
demande aux gens dans la rue de me faire
leurs meilleurs ta mère tu veux l'être
ouais bien sûr bon ta mère elle est
tellement grosse que quand elle monte
sur la balance à affiches sont
appréciables
andrea bon ajoute corinne salaires
renoir c'est quoi un roman qui a de
l'acné
vas-y un crunch c'est quoi un bric à
brac n'est ce pas crunch ou un renoir
puberté chez moi comme tu veux
[Musique]
encore pas raciste j'ai une amie noir
qui s'appelle florence tu peux la bière
[Musique]
danse je crois qu'elle est occupé la
seconde à une sur qui sont la main sur
les personnes de petite taille alors
agité coûté j qu'est-ce que ça un
activiste du mois à n'importe quoi
[Musique]
je suis moi c'est quoi la [ __ ] sur les
portions de frites rassure tu peux la
refaire s'il te plaît qu'est ce que
c'est un acquis qui c'est qui qu'est ce
que c'est un an
chaput bas laisse tomber quand on le
voit le père fouras journée à temps
est-ce que tu déteste par dessus tout à
la télé comme patron et à l'arrivée
j'aime bien voir exemple les princes
mais moi j'aime pas qu'est ce que tu
penses des candidates et les rires non
je ne sais pas trop globalement je suis
pas trop fan c'est l'emballage
mon dieu j'ai télé réalité la gdc gentil
disait qu'il aimait bien les candidats
effectivement à la caméra de son nom on
allait on allait on a le rush on peut
tous regardés on peut voir qu'il est je
vous le disais ça c'est que j'aimais
bien
j'aimais bien mais moi j'ai dit que
j'aimais bien et est resté sage les dix
sages l'es10 puis a commencé à donner
des qualités et des événements j'adore
heureux événement j'avais une
personnalité du show à la télé real en
global man tu moi je suis pour moi je
suis pour globalement je suis pas trop
fan et sarah tu vas pas laid ça c'est ça
l'humanité c'est exactement ce qu'il a
dit vraiment c'était moquons gauche qui
l'a dit c'est directement ses doutes
[Applaudissements]